[Music]
we keep hearing those most at risk from
koban 19 are the elderly and that's true
but there are exceptions Georges Laraque
is a big exception he's 43 years old 6
foot 3 and fit Georges Laraque is a
former NHL enforcer for 12 seasons he
was one of the toughest guys on the ice
he does have asthma but he says he's the
kind of guy who rarely gets sick and yet
this is where he ended up in early May
in a Quebec hospital diagnosed with
kovat 19 just before I got here I was
running to complete a marathon next year
five six days a week ten kilometers
every day and now I can't even get up
without losing my breath it's insane I
wake up in sweats all the time and you
know what I'm not you're the one
fighting this so don't feel sorry for
myself it's okay
with pneumonia in both lungs he spent
five days in the hospital and is now
recovering at home in self-isolation
and Georges Laraque is feeling well
enough to talk to us today George thanks
for doing this did you ever for a second
imagine you'd be one of the people who
ended up in the hospital with Kovac 19
actually thought it was no not a
proportion and I'm not I thought I was
gonna get it there's no way I I thought
it was only affecting older people and
that if I was gonna get it I was not
gonna have any symptoms well it came
back and blew me right in my face
because I end up at the hospital and
brought me a big piece of humility yeah
well I know you had trouble breathing
you had a fever tell us what it felt
like to go through the symptoms well you
know at the beginning I had chills and
you know I was in bed I I told me wet my
bed when I woke up in the morning I was
like what's going on my body I'm never
sick and my breathing started to be a
bit hard and I wanted to ask that all
because it was weird I didn't know why I
was feeling this way and I wanted to get
checked because I was they'll bring food
to elderly people them like if I'm sick
I need to tell them so when I went to
the Austral they did an x-ray and then
they checked me out and they were like
we don't need to do the tests
your lawns a bit a bit swollen so they
give me some quarters on build a second
home
but then my swarming in my dreaming was
getting worse and worse and when you
have asthma you're a bit a bit worried
when you're reading isn't it harder
because you wonder what's gonna happen
and you never wanted to stop but then
the Austral calls me back and they said
the doctor made a mistake in your x-ray
and you have pneumonia
I'm like what so wound up going back to
the Ostrom on Thursday and things work
my breathing was much harder and I was
not when I was at the office though I
was like listen I need a test I need to
tell the other difference sick so he
could go get checked so they did a test
and then they said yes you had it and
yet the ammonia in your lungs and you
plug me to the oxygen that that went
through my nose and I just take me back
to the first time you went to the
hospital and you asked for a testing and
they said no what reason did they give
you they said that they didn't have
enough and they need to save them and
whatever have it or not it wasn't
important I'm like yes it's important
because these elderly people that needs
to know my status so the second time
when I was so mad and I asked for it
they were like well you know knowing
death they should have did it the first
time I'm like so they didn't even agree
with the fact that they didn't do it the
first time it was so weird but at least
I'm happy that all the elderly that was
delivering food they all got tested
because I was positive and they were all
negative so that's a relief but what do
you think that the fact that you didn't
get a test initially that there was
confusion says about the sort of system
in Quebec about testing people that the
system here is no good
it's no good it makes zero sense me if I
was delivering food to elderly people
reason I'm doing a job that it's
essential if I can't even get tested so
they could be safe what is the safety
others when I was at the osteon I was
talking to the nurse you know what they
told me the nerves that are going to war
every single day to help out the people
that are suffering [ __ ] bed they said
George we feel so bad because before we
go home we can't even get tested to know
for bringing the disease at home to our
family do you have any idea where you
picked it up yeah I do when I was doing
all the rules
shopping I have this bad habit every
time I put my hair back to touch my face
I always do that now I'm gonna have to
wear elastic because when you go to
grocery store you wash your hand in your
car you Prell before you start driving
but that's my face maybe 2030 times
before I even wash my hand because I'm
always putting my hair back like this
and when you touch it when you grabbing
stuff it's the worst thing and again I
didn't think it was that contagious
so I was doing it anyway but now I know
George if you felt before like you were
never going to get this disease or if
you did you wouldn't get very sick what
message do you have now for people who
are your age have your fitness level who
might also think that they're almost
immune what you know what I would say to
them is that take this seriously and and
if it's not for yourself knowing that
you're young you might recovery from it
but that's before the people around you
because you don't know who you're gonna
be in contact with but maybe you'll be
in contact with with somebody that the
immune system is not strong enough maybe
somebody that is recovering from cancer
and that's what you have to think about